Ryan Reynolds getting a nomination in
the best song category would make the
next year of my life in sufferable uh
yeah they're at it again Hugh Jackman
continues his ongoing playful Feud with
Ryan Reynolds by begging the academy to
not nominate Reynolds for his recent
performance in Apple TV spirited
Jackman took to his social media to
express his excitement for the new year
however news that the academy had
shortlisted good afternoon from Spirited
for best song left the actor feeling
less than thrilled
good afternoon please from the bottom of
my heart
do not validate Ryan Reynolds in this
way but you did give credit where it was
due by expressing his love for spirited
and praising The Works of Will Ferrell
Octavia Spencer and everyone involved
except Ryan that is love spirited love
will love Octavia love the song Good
afternoon love binge and Justin of
course Hugh shared the exact reason he
doesn't want Ryan to be nominated and I
have to spend a year with him shooting
Wolverine and Deadpool and it
trust me it would be impossible it'd be
a problem to which Reynolds responded to
his faux rival on Instagram wishing him
a good afternoon while also tweeting
disagree I think the Deep fakes that
sung and dance for will and I would love
to perform at the Oscars